hey we're late for the small data Meetup
are you coming
I can't I'm waiting for this bigquery
job to finish can you wait eighteen
point two seconds but then all the
sparkling water is gonna be gone come on
okay well at that point is it even worth
going then well I bet if you use big
quarries clustering and partitioning
features your queries would run much
faster and cheaper that'd be great can
you show me how yeah let's do it
see bigquery is a great tool for
analyzing huge amounts of data quickly
but there are plenty of times we only
care to analyze a subset of your data
for example you may only want to look at
data over a particular period of time or
over a particular column if you check
out the illustration on the screen you
can see that I'm converting my unordered
table on the left into a date partition
table on the right and clustering my
tags closer together this is really
going to optimize my queries when I
analyze my data now looking at my GCP
project you can see that I have a stack
overflow dataset which contains a table
with ten point eight million Stack
Overflow questions which have been
gathered since 2014
this was pulled from the bigquery Stack
Overflow public data set by the way
which everyone has access to from the
schema you can see that this table
contains a bunch of great information
from each stack overflow question such
as the ID title body creation date
number of comments what's been tagged
with view count etc that's a lot of data
across ten point eight million Stack
Overflow questions so let's say you want
to gather some information on the types
of questions being asked about Android
in the last six months to accomplish
this I wrote the simple sequel query we
can see that we only care about dates in
the last six months and anything that
has the tag Android in it when running
this query against my standard table it
has to scan all of the data and all of
the tags and the creation date column so
you can see that it takes a few seconds
and scans the full 18 gigabytes of data
now if we set up the table to be
partitioned bigquery will only scan the
parts of the table that fall into this
date range ideally you should start
using partitioning when you first create
your table however I'll run a DDL or
data definition language query to create
a new table from this existing table and
use the creation underscore date column
as my custom partitioning column now
let's run that query against my
partition table
you can see that it returns in about a
quarter of the time and scans about a
tenth of the amount of data impressive
so let me get this straight
bigquery is taking care of all of the
hard work yep you just tell it what date
field you want to partition by and
bigquery knows exactly what partition
range was to use to maximize efficiency
but what if I want to partition my data
on something like a text column ah
that's where clustering comes in let me
show you looking at this query we're
taking advantage of partitioning because
we're filtering by creation date however
the query still needs to scan across all
the tags to find out which ones are
Android even though we're only looking
for a single keyword clustering is a way
for bigquery to optimize the placement
of your data and allows it to store
alike data closer together to make
queries more efficient typically
clustering works best on high
cardinality fields which maximizes the
amount of benefit you'll get by the way
you can cluster multiple columns so you
aren't limited to just one just like
partitioning you should set up
clustering at the get-go so I'll run a
similar DDL as before to create a new
table but this time we'll cluster our
data using the column tags so now if we
run these queries with clustering we can
see that we get our results slightly
faster and we're now scanning megabytes
of data instead of gigabytes so if I use
big queries partitioning and clustering
I'll only scan the data that I need to
save both time and money
exactly it takes a little bit more work
upfront but it's definitely worth it and
for those of you watching at home check
out the link in the description to try
it out for yourselves don't forget to
Like comment and subscribe for more
great Google cloud platform content
[Music]